there is a lot we can learn from
combining technology with science to
help support the development of amazing
discoveries by using an AI system to
predict protein shapes we have the
potential to accelerate research in
every field of biology inside every cell
in your body billions of tiny molecular
machines are hard at work they're what
allow your eyes to detect light your
neurons to Fire and the instructions in
your DNA to be read and these intricate
machines are known as proteins
well technically yes but let's zoom in
to a molecular level protein folding is
something that occurs naturally so that
proteins become biologically functional
but it's a complex process that
sometimes fails for decades scientists
have been trying to find a method to
reliably predict a protein structure
from its sequence of amino acids so we
can better understand how proteins work
there are over 200 million known
distinct proteins each one has a unique
3D shape that determines how it works
and what it does because there are so
many sequences and determining their 3D
structure experimentally is so time
consuming and expensive scientists only
know the exact structure of a tiny
little fraction of the proteins and
these experimental methods still fall
short of a reliable statistical accuracy
in 2020 alphabet's artificial
intelligence research armed deepmind
made a massive breakthrough in
predicting protein structures using a
deep learning model called malfo fold
Alpha fold is trained on publicly
available data consisting of about 170
000 protein structures and is the first
computational method that can regularly
predict the 3D shape of a protein at
scale with a high degree of accuracy
deepmind focuses on solving intelligence
to advance science and benefit Humanity
deepmind applies their Cutting Edge
research to alphabet products and
infrastructure used by billions of
people to solve Global and complex
problems
their most recent version Alpha fold 2
was validated in the prediction
challenge Casp 14. it's already sent
waves throughout the scientific
community and has demonstrated the
potential for AI to Aid fundamental
scientific discovery and deepmind has
made Alpha fold predictions available
and open source to anyone to date more
than 500 000 researchers from 190
countries have accessed the alpha full
database to get closer to finding
life-saving cures for diseases like
Chagas and now deepmind has expanded the
set of available predictions by more
than 200x from nearly 1 million to
nearly 214 million to cover almost all
cataloged proteins found in nature we've
released this data set of predicted
protein structures for plants bacteria
animals and other organisms as part of
the Google Cloud public data set program
to enable bulk downloads at no cost yeah
that means you can also create custom
queries of the data set using bigquery
but you might also want to run Alpha
full reliably on your own and there are
a few key challenges to keep in mind
you need to set up feature engineering
against genetic sequence databases
pre-processed data and run those inputs
against pre-trained models and all of
this requires allocating CPUs or gpus
hosting a notebook environment and
scaling up for larger experiments
it's pretty hard to build and configure
an on-premise system or Cloud Server to
use Alpha fold whether you just want to
try it out or run it at scale as a large
organization and that's why we're
excited to share a deep integration
between Google cloud and deepmind
on top of the public data sets program
we've integrated Alpha fold into vertex
AI a managed end-to-end ml platform to
help address these challenges and speed
up deployment with Alpha fold on vertex
AI you can manage a data science or a
machine learning workflow in a single
development environment you get access
to pre-configured compute storage and
end-to-end production notebooks we've
removed the heavy lifting needed to set
up new ml environments automate
orchestration and manage large clusters
the alpha fold inference workflow can be
simplified with vertex AI from data
preparation and model training to
feature engineering and deployment
unlike the manual setup the orchestrator
makes it possible to parallelize steps
get predictions faster and with better
tracking for those of you who want to
try out a simplified version of alpha
fold against a smaller protein database
we have an alpha fold python notebook
that you can deploy right on vertex
workbench which lets you specify a
custom container image that we have
already created for you you'll be able
to download the alpha fold data
configure GPU acceleration search
against genetic databases and use the
pre-process results as inputs to the
alpha fold model locally in a little
over an hour you can harness the power
of alpha fold to generate 3D protein
structures from amino acid sequences for
organizations that want to run a
full-blown version of alpha fold for
many protein folding experiments a week
you'll want an ml pipeline orchestrator
the alpha fold batch inference solution
is a set of code samples that uses
vertex AI pipelines to support hundreds
of concurrent inference pipelines with
higher throughput to help you run
experiments at scale the solution uses
vertex pipelines as an orchestrator and
runtime vertex metadata for metadata and
artifacts and file store to manage
databases
because it's built on vertex AI
pipelines you can automate Monitor and
experiment with interdependent parts of
an ml workflow the minimized inference
elapsed times means what normally would
take you days can now take you hours the
solution includes two example Pipelines
the universal pipeline solution mirrors
the exact logic in deepmind's open
source inference script but decoupled
into discrete tasks so you can run the
same experiments faster more efficiently
and with better tracking the customized
pipeline solution shows you how to
further optimize the inference workflow
by parallelizing feature engineering
steps so you can plug in your own
proprietary database sources
you get example components pipelines and
notebooks to start analyze and recompile
pipelines on different gpus
the alpha fold vertex AI workbench
solution is great for experimental use
while the alpha fold batch inference
Solution on vertex pipelines is great
for doing protein folding at scale with
a strong process for reproducibility and
tracking
from a 50-year challenge to the
discovery of alpha fold to being able to
easily run it on Google Cloud
researchers developers and science
enthusiasts now have access to one of
the most pivotal advancements in the
medical world the next answers to the
mysteries of life and discovery of
disease treatments have never felt more
attainable with these no cost solutions
to run Alpha fold on vertex Ai and the
public data set it can help Propel Us in
this worldwide Endeavor you can get
started with Alpha fold on Google Cloud
by checking out the links below and
learn more about deepmind by checking
out their research and their Channel
subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this and thanks for watching
[Music]